[Musique]
et oui c'est une nouvelle polémique qui
vient frapper miss france succès du vol
c'est du vol
alors que pour la première fois dans
l'histoire du concours les 29 candidates
régionales ont bénéficié d'un contrat de
travail et c'est des concours donc à un
moment ça n'est pas du travail voilà que
leur salaire vient d'être révélée par le
parisien et pour certaines il est plus
que dérisoire on a été payé 84 euros par
jour soit 252 euros nets en tout
l'équivalent du smic c'est vraiment
symbolique au delà de dénoncer une
exploitation financière d'autres misent
déplore le manque de nourriture tout au
long de la préparation du concours
certaines d'entre elles auraient perdu
jusqu'à 6 kg du côté de la productrice
alexia laroche joubert il n'y a pas de
polémique pas question d'augmenter ou
d'allonger la durée du contrat cela ne
correspond pas à nos valeurs et les
motivations des candidates ne seraient
plus les mêmes pour ça elle peut faire
les marseillais où les ch'tis de quoi
prévenir celle qui voudrait se présenter
l'année prochaine alors manque de
nourriture petits salaires êtes vous
choqué par les conditions des candidates
à miss france
alors qu'est ce qui se passe maintenant
moi je suis pas choqué je suis choqué
par les déclarations des miss france
dida les passes à luton de vous mais
elle n'avait pas de contrat ils en ont
on a réclamé ici qu'elle en est à l on
noie pour trois jours elles sont là
vraiment dit impose au bout c'est grâce
à vous et finalement non mais a réclamé
c'est pas que cet amendement
elle est persuadée d'avoir 45 40 mais
qui volent à la can face à l'autisme
propre plus grand producteur de
l'e3 pour endemol
[Applaudissements]
non mais c'est bon là on va se dissoudre
et tout ce que j'attendais beaucoup de
ce côté là
aujourd'hui pour souffler tout faire
souffler tout ça et c'est bien dans des
conditions magnifiques à la réunion et
se plaignent d'un mal manger c'est
complètement ridicule c'est vrai si
elles font ça pour l'argent faut faire
autre chose dit on est en train de tuer
miss france et je laisserai pas faire 21
points l'argentin sert à combler nous
mêmes des people pour l'argent a pas du
tout
[Rires]
alors jamais de la vie je ne pourrai
jamais d'argent avec vous on est la
risée de la raison je vais vous raconter
une anecdote des
sentiments voignier geodis je m'envolais
vu leur part du début de l'automne il
m'a envoyé un sms la messe est
aujourd'hui est-ce qu'on est obligé de
tout aujourd'hui transport salut baby
salubrité et je ne parle pas anglais
est-ce que tu m'autorise à demander à
h2o que j'achète un costume pour tpm
people tiendra
pas dit la vérité les rowdies me dire tu
as il était là et on gagne sur la joue
comme tout le monde je dis pas ce type
est un people je te vois en animateur à
jaws là c'est un beau costume ajouté un
beau costume neuf mois on dort jamais
tout acheter des costumes chez toi moi
j'adore
un
costume je lui envoie ça ils répondent
pas quand même pas lui j'ai même pas
j'ai tout à l'heure je vois que je dis
qu'est ce que c'est pour le costume
gamme mais il faut que tu parles à la
prod pour salah un souci on peut temps
prêté un voilà les manoeuvres est un
jogging samedi
[Rires]
samedi occupez-vous de miss france pour
l'instant la concurrence et tout
doucement à 100 que je m'apprêtais
depuis le début ce que j'avais dit c'est
que c'est la fin des miss france c'est
pourquoi ma dernière année parce que
maintenant l'un foot en plus d'émissions
parle de quoi les contrats des mauvaises
conditions elles sont pas contentes il
ya plus de pub lien vous la merde
maintenant laisser dire si cette taxe
est bien aussi c'est une belle émission
aussi ça me représente la france est
scellé nouvelle marianne et c'est vrai
qu'on en a besoin
de venir
[Applaudissements]
parce que la comté et c'est vrai que
maintenant quand on en parle c'est pour
dire quoi elle va le contrat de travail
c'est vrai cette des ridicules les
comptes 10 mai musique et en même temps
on regarde en famille c'est comme une
religion on regarde tout c'est la
famille franciliens c'est la famille
france pour vous
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
ben moi pour vous bon matin il dit ses
lapins mr oui c'est triste moi j'ai
enquêté j'ai recueilli le témoignage
manon j'ai recueilli le témoignage de
nombreux smith et c'est vraiment
éreintant pour être cette préparation et
sur le sujet de la nourriture c'est un
manque de nourriture c'est pour ne pas
qu'elles grossissent apparent en
coulisses on leur reproche vraiment
inadmissible a dit que on lui reprochait
de manger une pomme par exemple non
répond pas quelle couleur si c'est vrai
ça les filles elles c'est chaud ça mais
c'est une vraie joie et une petite dame
en question
petites phrases condensé en coulisses tu
vois l'animal rose dans la ferme tu
voudrais pas y ressembler fait attention
à ce que tu manges c'est pas bien non
c'est une vraie phrase ça voilà mais
malheureux ils voulaient pas qu'il
ressemble à une poule
ça si c'est ça c'est un vestige été
mauvais en animal
oui tu dis n'importe quoi comme
d'habitude cette émission c'est un
carton intersidéral alors bis records
c'est éreintant excuse moi dormir c'est
éreintant caissière sert un temps
chauffeur-livreur sert à préparer un
concours de miss france c'est pas
toujours les rageuse et les aigris qui
disent que ça se passe pas bien qu'elles
peuvent pas manger à leurs patients
n'ont pas payé tout ça comme par hasard
c'est elle qui gagne tout s'est bien
passé excuse moi il ya un concours et
quand il ya un concours il ya des
critères et des critères c'est injuste a
donc forcément celles qui sont mieux
gaulle et celle qu'on trouve plus joli
et ben ils vont peut-être gagner c'est
comme ça voilà tu peux a déploré
alors là la ville elle a tout dit
l'atout de j